parmi papa papa papa ma femme tom par
amsata fall quasi mais on en fera pas
c'est toi qui m'a fait peur à moi j'ai
remarqué oui tu as tellement sursauter
que tu as perdu l'équilibré
ah qu'est ce que tu cherches ben ça que
j'ai perdu mais y'a rien tu n'a rien
perdu que dix mille turcs viennent me
dire que j'ai sursauté et que j'ai perdu
quelque chose tu as perdu l'équilibré
ça veut dire que tu as failli tomber par
terre l' équilibre c'est un mot très
important qui signifie dans ton cas
particulier la position verticale du
corps comme ça mais c'est un mot qui
signifie beaucoup d'autres choses moi
alors je l' ai trouvé mon équilibre là
évidemment du doigt bien
bon alors je comprends pas pourquoi tu
mens nuit avec une chose qui n'existe
plus là ou que tu prépares qu'au gp red
bull alors que je l' ai déjà trouvé
d'accord casimir d'accord avec toi je
jeu préférant rester là plutôt que
d'entrer dans une conversation aussi
compliqué bon ben je te laisse se
répéter à danser à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure pam padam padam papa me
par an pas vraiment pas bon ou non en
soi bien voir monsieur duchesneau a
perdu l'équilibré
je vous aimais monsieur nov le testament
que les gens à nous de faire attention
que l'idiot ce magazine you inattention
oui il arrive derrière moi sans prévenir
toute façon tu es un incapable
tu ne pourras jamais rien de bien je ne
vous salue pas monsieur o tu l'as
entendu tour être fâché il est fâché un
bon je vais lui prouver mois que je suis
capable de faire quelque chose tout seul
et aujourd'hui même
bravo casimir les caisses que du vin
c'est bien je vais achever un je vais je
vais je ne fais pas j'ai aucune idée
salut bonjour julie par bonjour ou
mais ça n'a pas l'air d'aller toi je
parie que tu t'es encore disputé avec
monsieur 10,9
oui c'est ça de gagné julie il énerve
tout le temps à les oublier vos petites
querelles
regardez je rapportais de chez mon amie
sophie des légumes splendide les enfants
venir oui en venir je vais vous montrer
des légumes comme on en voit rarement ce
que vous connaissez leur nous on est
tous là regardez on va tous les passés
en revue
vous allez me dire leur nom et sous dont
la partie comme morges se trouve dans la
terre ou au dessus de la terre d'accord
c'est un regard caroline ce gros là
qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
c'est un soufflage quoi et dans un
souffle à la chauffe la partie qu'on
mange c'est dans la terre ou au dessus
de la terre et celui là c'est quoi
qu'est ce que tu dit david salade
non c'est bien ça c'est un show tout
court avancez à choux fleurs ça c'est un
chedjou est ce qu'on mange c'est dans la
tête ou au dessus de la terre
très bien juhlin ah ça qu'est ce que
c'est c'est joli
caroline benoit nadine c'est du céleri
et ce qu'on mange c'est dans la terre ou
au dessus de la terre un triple problème
vous avez raison tous les deux parce que
ce que je tient dans la main sa soeur de
la terre en l'ange est en dessous il ya
une grosse boule au stress encore ap et
qui est dans la terre et qu'on mange
également donc dans celle rio marche qui
a dans la terre est au dessus de la
terre pierre jeunet
évidemment et là il a tout le monde va
trouver
est ce qu'on mange c'est dans la terre
ou au dessus de la terre et qu'est ce
que c'est bon pour moi ce comité
roussillon a dit tiens j'ai dit voilà
encore un autre
non je crois pas là je savais c'est un
poireau est ce qu'on mange c'est dans la
terre ou au dessus de la terre à la
terre dans la terre mais tellement
d'amour entre mois de vide votre moi
qu'est ce qu'on mange
voilà on manche est parti tient julie
dans la terre très bien j'espère que
chez eux nos amis cherchent c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est en façade on en fait
de la salade
c'est d'une endive la salade d'endives
c'est délicieux alors c'est dans la
maison avec de la boue au dessus de la
terre c'est au dessus de 10 un joli
ballon au dessus en dessous vous aviez
trouvé chez vous par fait tjrs un joli
placement je commence à qu'est ce que
c'est que ça haricots par la ricoh est
ce qu'on mange les gens je vous le
montrer ce qu'on mange c'est à
l'intérieur
voilà ah oui oui oui les petites graines
alors ça se trouve dans la terre ou au
dessus de la terre
sur la route soit parfait tiens julie se
remettait à ricco d'entente a nié qu'est
ce que je vous invite à lire avec tout
ça je les bats avec de tels légumes
je ne peux faire qu'une soupe excellente
à part ça je dis va nous faire une bonne
soupe
venez par à jouer les entoure bon ok
julie oui je dis moi tu laisses tient
qu'avec tous ces légumes
on ne peut pas rater une soupe à base je
suis certaine qu'il fallait aussi bon
alors je voulais accumulé donne tous les
deux nés ouais pourquoi
eh bien je vais faire une soupe très
réussi et comme ça je pourrai prouver à
monsieur du club que je suis capable de
faire quelque chose
non mais alors à une seule condition la
terre c'est que tu ne te servira que de
légumes et une ajoutera pas de la crème
d'escargots de la crème chantilly où la
belle fille aux framboises
c'est promis voilà merci tu vas voir je
lis tu vas pouvoir être fier de moi
double erreur une de ses sous ohlala
[Musique]
il ne faut pourtant pas tellement de
temps pour faire une soupe mais il a
peut-être fait brûler ils n'osent pas
venir nous le dira
tu pourrais pas les versions on ne veut
surtout pas non il n'aime pas ça ici je
prends un chemin différent du sien
joris de le croiser et de le rater le
nom il vaut mieux attendre ici bien sûr
tu en voilà abbas et lui désignant tu
étais long aux yeux ou ceux qui étaient
avec parce que je suis d'abord passer
chez monsieur du snob
il n'était pas là mais je lui ai laissé
un grand bol de soupe sur sa table il va
être et pathé elle est vraiment
délicieux chana mois et alors on dirait
de l'alcool quoi ma soupe de la colle
bon c'est très bien je vais aller la
manger tout seul il faut que je te
félicite pardonnez moi mes amis je ne
vous salue pas je dois féliciter casey
millésime à féliciter en effet quasi mis
cette fois ci tu m'as vraiment épaté
j'ai un ami industriel chez moi qui est
aux commandes dit neal peau dit 10000
bout de 200 mais vous l'avez vraiment
goûté ça souffle qui parle de soupe
c'est la plus extraordinaire cool que je
connaisse regardez casimir a laissé
tomber quelques gouttes sur ma table
lorsqu'il a posé ce bonne on a été
incapable de le décoller finalement j'ai
été obligé de casser ma table s'est
exprimée nous